our question dr. John comes from Michael
in New York my company just furloughed
50% of the company the executives have
taken a 50% pay cut they just sent a
communication asking for volunteers to
reduce her salary for a short time as
well I was thinking of cutting my salary
by 5% which is my current 401k
percentage I have an emergency fund set
up what are your thoughts generous yeah
thoughtful so yeah I mean the people are
leading with a greater percentage than
they're taking a cut then you are then
they're asking you guys and it was a
volunteer and it's something you can do
I don't know how big your company is or
what the sense of camaraderie or loyalty
is if it was zero and you're treated
like a widget that works there I
wouldn't there's no point because you're
saving a bunch of people that don't even
know you exist or something like that
but if you've got a great camaraderie
unity and in the thing I think it's
worth the sacrifice at that point and I
love a leadership team that goes first I
love a leadership team that says here's
yours we're putting our money where our
mouth is if you don't go first by
definition you're not a leader there you
go and I also like I like the
camaraderie I also like this notion that
I've got a responsibility to who I see
in the mirror to and what's what can I
do to participate in help and I've lived
like no one else and then here came a
moment right yeah so with the CEO was
shot with a simon Sinek and a think tank
thing over an ash pan back in the fall
and the guy running the thing I was a
CEO of a company with 12,000 employees
and they got in a financial crunch not
not a coronavirus thing this was back in
the fall and they got in a financial
crash years ago and in order to turn it
around the executive team took zero for
a while and they said we have to
furlough folks and they were able
because it was not like her own a virus
they were able to spread the furloughs
out and they said okay everybody's going
to lose a
week of pay during the next four months
you decide when that's best for you what
happened was employees who couldn't
afford afford to lose more than one
week's pay took two weeks of furlough so
that their buddy who was broke didn't
have to take any and that across the
aisle inside they've got factories all
over the world and but the people at was
all within each factory so it was the
guy you know you're talking I'm gonna
give George my week I'm gonna take his
week mmm so he doesn't have to take it
or whatever you say that and it was this
thing where you knew directly that the
person you were helping and they had a
little space it wasn't all crammed into
one month like this April of hell we
better right right if I never saw a
month I wanted to go away as fast as
this been the longest month could God
ever but you know the the but I think
that that that's a cool way of looking
at it and say okay you know leadership
teams taking nothing we still gonna have
to do it I mean we talked about it
around here we didn't have to do it we
were we were our revenues ended up
stabilizing and we were able to come up
with other ways to cover it and we
didn't get into a thing leadership
didn't even have to take a pay cut here
so far anyway we were prepared to before
we did something but we said okay rather
than lay off the last hundred hired out
of our thousand we'll let everybody take
a cut equal to what that pay would have
been that's good because I was in that
group you're the last wonder that would
have been good I think when you give
people an opportunity to serve and to
take care of people especially as you
mentioned it I can look him in the eye
it's the same thing we experienced with
these tornadoes a few seems like a
hundred years ago now but just people
showing up with meals and food and
cookies and signs and chainsaws people
will do it if you let them if you let
them when you impose it on them then our
natural inclination is put your hands up
well that's why this idea of the
taxation is somehow tied to charity hmm
is ridiculous
there is no virtue in you taxing me
there's virtue that transfers when
someone gives me money or I give someone
money
if I give you my sandwich that's virtue
there you but if you if a policeman
comes up takes it away from me and gives
it to you there's no virtue transfer yes
that's right and so there's no
generosity so to equate taxation with
generosity is absolutely asinine
it's a ridiculous concept or it's
punting your responsibility or your
willingness to get chance there didn't
get there but it's actually saying I'm
gonna help you be charitable
that's instead of me do it mmm I think
you ought to be more charitable than you
are so I'm gonna do it for you I don't
do the hard work of finding the needs of
my community you do it and it is hard
work
of it absolutely it is and it's messy
work I have found out that giving is
harder than I ever imagined doing it
intelligently wisely and not bringing
harm you know and instead not not
enabling not us not us not participating
in their insanity something like that
actually causing change and
transformation and lift with giving it's
a lot of work that's been a neat move I
think over the last five or ten years
where philanthropist people of means are
looking around saying I'm not just
throwing money in the wind anymore I
want I want to see that this is going to
help people to help the trajectory be
different had a billionaire sit down
with me about ten years ago and he said
he chided me a little bit because I was
asking him about it so he I said it I
set myself up right but a t-ball
question I mean I set himself up on the
tee ball right and popped me in the head
and he said you know you are so careful
with your investing you're so diligent
with picking out good investments and
when it comes to giving God's money you
just throw it hmm he said you need to be
more diligent with your giving and wise
with your giving and treat it like it's
investing because you're investing God's
money mmm
man it convicted me that's when we
formed our family foundation I mean
within six months of that I had you know
Denise his head of it and for ten years
she's been running that thing and we
were getting better and better and
better and more and more careful and
lots of lots of checks and balances to
make sure we're wise with that
generosity but you do you want to see
the return you want to see lift from it
well you know Ramzi solutions if y'all
don't know we gave away 168 tanks of gas
one morning at two different gas
stations with about 30 of us went out
there with their gloves and their masks
on and I'm out there cleaning
windshields and for health care workers
we put signs out there and said
hey your healthcare worker coming will
give you free tank of gas and it was so
powerful because you got to see you my
gratitude Act you got you know the tears
and the thank you and nobody said thank
you and I'm so tired and this means so
much it lifts my whole day up and on and
I don't know you know one was had a sour
face there was no one they might have
cuz someone had master home but you
here's another important thing about
what you're the the buddy at the think
tank said he had created a culture over
a series of months and years that when a
crisis showed up everybody had the
spirit and heart to make it happen and
we we wait till the house is on fire
before we start trying to communicate
directly to each other right or we start
to culture is about setting things up
way in advance having a good marriage
having good relationships knowing
yourself well you got to do that stuff
before the house catches on fire and
otherwise because spirit is gonna be
stress tested you mentioned it the other
day when you squeeze something you find
out what the juice is and that's why you
know we've sadly are seeing divorces go
through the roof right now man doors
filings in this thirty day period of
time earth skyrocketed domestic violence
skyrocketed and the suicide rates hmm
have you seen those no I haven't we got
to pull those up you and I got to talk
about that on the air okay I saw I did a
drive-by on it sound of it right right
down but the number of suicides due to
associated with unemployment is going to
approach the Cova deaths
wow that's what this article was saying
I gotta go I gotta pull it up and source
it for I mmm where I stand on it is
absolute truth but bottom line is is
there's all this other stuff going on oh
this is revealed where we were revealed
our spiritual condition our financial
condition or disconnection are our
social condition are hatefulness towards
one another our love and generosity
towards one another it is revealed all
of that and somehow it's beautiful and
some of it is really scary when you see
it so much some of the things that's
revealed some of the things that my son
Daniel and I have breakfast every
Tuesday morning it's we had breakfast
this morning he's one of our top leaders
in the organization here and we were
talking about from a leadership
perspective some of the things you've
learned and I had told him the breakfast
some of the things this revealed in me I
didn't
hmm you know I just made me reassess and
I mean you know I I get why I do that
but it's still not okay in that that
Dave is wisdom that's why you're a great
leader because you can look in the
mirror and say this time but not again
yeah that's wisdoms embarrassing when
you look in the mirror